I think it was a risky, risky
tough undertaking for Stephen
and colleagues to build
a university today that
was meant to compete with
institutions like ours
for students and in quality.
And they had as their goals--
I just want to give
you the shape of it
before you have the plenary
conversation of what Minerva,
has been, is all about.
The goals were to educate for
global leadership, the ability
to think broadly and
adaptively to learn
how and when to innovate
in order to solve
complex problems for today.
They identified four
core competencies,
thinking critically,
thinking creatively,
communicating effectively,
and interacting effectively.
And they built about 100
habits of mind and foundational
concepts that were behind
those core competencies.
Every student who
attends Minerva
is expected to be actively
involved in every class.
Every lesson is tied to
specific learning outcomes.
Every learning experience draws
on a combination of those 16
signs of learning principles.
There are no lectures.
Students engage with one another
through an online platform
called the Active
Learning Forum.
And it supports real-time,
synchronous small seminars.
And they don't have a campus.
They have seven cities that
are-- that form the campus,
and students use them as
their learning progresses.
It was a bold move.
It is a bold move,
but it's not anymore
what Stephen is tied to.
He's got a new enterprise
that he's been working on.
And it draws on many
of these same ideas,
and I hope that we'll
hear a little bit more
about that today.
It is my great pleasure
to quickly introduce
the three remarkable
people who will
be part of our kickoff plenary.
Again, I'm not
going to read bios
because you have them there.
I want to say I am very
grateful to Claudine Gay,
our new faculty of
Arts and Sciences dean,
for agreeing to moderate
this discussion,
and I cannot imagine, as I
said to her as we thought about
this, someone who was more
perfectly placed to be able
to do this work given
her scholarly background,
given her commitment
to education.
Stephen, as you will see in
the bios, if you look at them,
was dean of social sciences
at Harvard years ago,
and Claudine has most recently
been in that same position.
So there's a really nice
institutional, organizational
synergy here.
Stephen happened to be a mentor
for me when I first taught.
The very first time I taught
as a grad student sophomore
tutorial, he was head tutor.
And I learned more
from how he talked
about what we were doing
in those tutorial classes
about teaching and learning
than I have anywhere else
and about how to run
a very tight meeting,
like we never wasted time.
Time was an incredibly
precious in those.
And I am also very grateful
to you for being here,
for continuing to
care about this place,
and for doing the work
that you've been doing
on the global, broader scale.
And Senator Kerrey you
know, what a legacy.
How many people get to
say Navy SEAL, Medal
of Honor, longstanding
service as a senator,
deep, deep, record
and commitment
to education, including being
president of an institution?
And I found in our short
phone conversations leading up
to today that the national
perspective that he gave, like,
we would be talking about
things on kind of this level.
And he'd just kick it up, kick
it out, and think about it
in this much broader way.
And it reminded me about the
New Englandy, Harvardy bubble
that I live in, and
so I hope that he
is able to also help to lift
you all out of our little New
Englandy, Harvardy
bubble as we think
about these important issues.
So please join me in welcoming
them to our kickoff plenary.
[APPLAUSE]
Well, good morning.
Good morning.
So you all sat there?
So I brought my dog eared copy
of "Building the Intentional
University."
It is a wonderfully
provocative book.
I'm not at all surprised
to hear that it sustained
such a lively conversation
among the faculty
over the course of a year.
There are so many
observations in here
that, as I read them, I--
they stung a bit.
They felt kind of familiar,
but I think they're important.
And so I actually just wanted
to start our conversation
with really one of
the central claims
in the book that actually proves
to be, by my understandings,
were motivating insight
for Minerva itself.
And that's the claim
that most colleges
fail to prepare graduates
for the kinds of problems
and challenges that they'll
encounter afterwards.
I think there was one statement
in the book at one point that
said something to the effect
of, remarkably little learning
happens on most
college campuses.
So let's start there.
So what do you see as some of
the most pressing challenges
that students who
are graduating now
and, say for the
next 5 or 10 years,
that they're going to be facing?
Did you make that claim?
Actually, it comes from a book
called Academically Adrift.
The subtitle is Minimal Learning
on College Campuses, something
to that that effect.
And it was based on
results from the CLA+,
which is a standardized test.
It's been administered
in many universities.
It showed remarkably
little learning.
Yeah.
Unlike the Senate.
OK.
It has also remarkably
little learning.
So what are-- so what are some
of the important challenges
that students need
to be prepared for?
Well, from my point of
view, the only thing
we can really be sure of is
things are going to change.
So from my point of view,
the paramount thing to do
is actually teach
students how to learn
so that they can continually
adapt as the world changes
around them.
And from my point of
view, the remarkable thing
is there's an enormous amount
now known about learning,
but almost none of it is
actually taught explicitly
anywhere actually in terms
of helping people figure out
for themselves how to learn, how
to adapt as the world changes.
So that's one thing.
The second thing is
Joseph Aoun, who's
president of another
institution in this area,
Northeastern, wrote a
really interesting book
called Robot Proof--
Higher Education in the Age
of Artificial Intelligence. .
And he thinks about this
in really some depth what
we're going to need to
teach going forward.
And he talks about three kinds
of things, if I remember right.
One is data literacy, being
able to deal with data.
One is technological literacy,
understanding machines
so you can interact with
machines because one thing we
do know, AI is on the march.
It's going to increase.
And the third thing is what
he called human literacy.
From my point of view, I
don't think the first two
are for everybody.
I don't think everybody is going
to want to become a data geek
and get really into how
you interact with machines.
But the human part I
see is really central.
And I think you can
unpack that, that
is think about what
it is that people
do that's going to be
really hard to automate
for the foreseeable future.
What kinds of things could
be hard to get AI to do.
So it's not that hard
to come up with a list--
soft skills, which aren't
soft at all, by the way.
They're very hard to teach,
sort of leadership, negotiation,
how you interact with other
people, communication,
that sort of thing.
We're always going to need
people who are good at that.
Creative analysis,
I mean, when you
think about how we
analyze problems,
we're really good at it.
We can sometimes change
what the problem is.
It's very hard to implement
these kinds of things.
And then problem solving,
which very difficult to do.
And then, lastly, is
just understanding
emotion and how to
communicate in a context
where emotions, as I gather
at some of these seminars,
can sometimes run
high and how that
can affect the context
of what you're doing.
So context in general
is something humans
are really good
at picking up on,
and it's very hard to
program machines do
that because it's open ended.
Every time there's a new news
article, that context changes.
It's open ended.
So from my point of view, Joseph
Aoun, the author of that book,
had at least part of it right
for everybody moving forward,
we should be teaching
the kinds of things
that are not likely to be
displaced by automation, by AI.
And we should be teaching
people how to learn and adapt
as the world changes.
Senator Kerrey, do
you want to add?
Well, I mean, I do tend
to orient to democracy
and what does it take to
produce individuals that
know how democracy operates?
What are the ideas
that belie democracy,
what are the techniques
that make it work,
and what are the commitments
necessary to sustain it?
And I'm not saying that
all of higher education
needs to be oriented that way.
But I'd like to see some
part of higher education
oriented that way.
And I think what
Stephen has done
in Minerva does prepare
those graduates to be
able to participate in
democracy in one way
that I think is
enormously important,
which is not just to be able
to do critical analysis,
but to be able to be a
better listener, to be
able to understand--
I mean, let's say--
I don't know how many
people are in this room.
250 people in this room?
Let's say we have to--
we have to decide which
door we're going to go out
of when this thing is over.
We get-- we have to decide--
we all have to decide,
and majority rules were all
going out the same door.
And once you're forced into
that kind of an environment,
now I have a problem
I got to solve.
I've got to try to--
I say, I decided I want
to go out that door.
You want to go out that door.
And we have to make an
effort to persuade people
that our position is correct.
And if we lose, we
have to understand
that there is a tomorrow, that
checking out doesn't work,
and it's appalling--
I'm going to associate
myself with a comedian I once
heard that said that
83.65% of all facts
are made up on the spot.
[LAUGHTER]
But I do have a fading
recollection of a survey that
was done a number of years
ago, where 75% of Americans
can name all three
of the Three Stooges,
but 20% can't name one
Supreme Court Justice, very
difficult for me to
imagine, and we now
have a president who knows
less than any president
in the history of the
country and revels in it.
He is actually selling the
idea that we're all better off
being stupid, genuinely does.
And we're not all
better off being stupid,
and it can be
difficult, by the way,
once we learn something that
conflicts with other people.
Maybe the most difficult of
all is when you come home,
and you say to your
mom and dad, I just
learned something that's
different than what
you've been telling me.
So learning something
that requires
you to confront an audience
that disagrees with you
is one of the central
challenges of democracy.
And I worry about it, and I--
I don't-- I don't
think it's singularly
Harvard's responsibility
or any other
university's responsibility, but
at some portion of the liberal
arts education needs to be
centered on the question,
are we preparing people
to be good citizens?
Do they understand
what they have to do?
It's not all about go out
and make the world better.
Sometimes we'll make
the world worse,
and then we have to correct.
We don't always do
the right thing.
So it seems to me that to
prepare men and women who
are leaving universities to
have the capacity to understand,
as I said, the ideas
that underlie democracy.
They're real ideas.
You know, they're 500
or 600 years old is all.
You've got commitments that
are necessary to make it work,
and you have techniques,
real techniques.
I mean, somebody said
to me the other day,
well, it's just all rhetoric.
What do you mean all rhetoric?
Of course rhetoric
is a real discipline.
You know, it's not--
I'm disparaging a
political conversation
because I'm saying
it's just rhetoric?
I wish it was just rhetoric.
It would be more
enjoyable if it was.
So these are ambitious goals.
So what's required for
responsible democratic
citizenship, understanding
human literacy, data literacy,
how do we reduce that into a
set of curricular components
that would be essential
to prepare students
for that kind of work?
Why do you use the word reduce?
Translate that.
It's kind of like an expression.
So I always-- I really enjoyed
Erin's introductory remarks
there, and you reminded me
of a book by Elisabeth Rozin.
You know this book?
I think it was called The
Flavor Principle, or something
like that, where what she did
is she analyzed ethnic cooking
and came up with a
set of principles,
rules, that were generative.
It was based on
generative grammars,
Chomskian kind of grammars.
So the idea was you
could have it both ways.
You could improvise,
but within a structure.
So you could--
Indian food, or Chinese
food, or whatever and not
according to a
lockstep set of recipes
where you had to follow
really precisely,
but according to a set
of general principles.
So it seems to me what
we really want to teach
are generative principles.
Things are going to change.
They're going to
go out of style.
I'm not going to
fixate on specifics.
We want to teach
things that will serve
in good stead moving forward.
So from my perspective, a
general education program
is absolute critical for that.
That's where you should
lay down the foundations.
But there's a problem.
We know from the
science of learning,
the greatest single challenge is
something called far transfer.
They learn something
in one context,
and then they just
don't use it in another.
There is near transfer where
the contexts are similar, far,
where they're quite
different, where there
is some underlying similarities,
not obvious how to transfer it.
The only way you can get far
transfer, as far as I can tell,
is make sure they
understand their principles
and give them lots of
varied examples over time.
So you can't just have a
general education program,
and then leave, and then just
forget about all that stuff.
It's somehow got
to be integrated
and picked up on in subsequent
components of the curriculum.
So the curriculum has
got general education.
It's got the majors.
It's got electives.
That's the curriculum.
You've got to get
threads that go through
and tie together,
integrate, and lead students
to see what the
underlying principles are
that can be generalized.
Right.
So I would be very
interested to hear you just
talk a little bit
about, especially
from your own experience,
about the work
of translating some set of
evidence-based principles
into action.
So you know, taking one example
from your own work, you know,
what is a principle that you
try to bring into your teaching,
into your leadership, that
was transformative for you,
that was especially effective?
How did you go about doing that?
So let me-- let me, if I
can start on this one--
Sure.
Two things that came out
of Minerva that I think
might be relevant
and interesting,
the first is the whole
science of learning piece,
sort of boiling down this
gigantic literature, which
I don't think anybody has read.
I've certainly not
read all of it.
But I've read a fair amount
and trying to figure out
how to actually implement that.
And as Erin pointed out, I
summarized that literature
as a chapter in that
book, organized it
into the 16 principles,
two of which
are interesting,
easy to understand,
which is space practice.
So just like you don't want
to have one thick coat.
So when I was younger,
I bought a used--
a graduate-- a
graduate student, I
bought a used desk
that was black.
It was hideous.
So I decided it would
look a lot better white.
But I was in a hurry, so I
poured the white paint onto it
and smeared it
around, let it dry,
and then you know it happened.
For a while, it looked OK, and
then it peeled up, and cracked.
You get what you--
yeah.
So the way you're supposed to
do it is a lot of thin coats.
OK, so spaced practice is like
thin coats staggered over time,
much better for
learning than cramming.
Cramming is the classic
example of massed practice.
It doesn't work well.
They'll learn it for the
test, and they forget it.
So trying to implement
that is difficult
because the typical tendency
is to teach this subject,
move to the next lecture,
teach that subject, next one.
Whereas spaced practice suggests
you got to be returning.
You've got to revisit
what you did before.
It's just hard to
actually implement that,
even though we know it works.
You can do it by having
quizzes that are cumulative.
That's one way that we hit on.
Another thing we did
is we tried to think
of a principal way of
producing the learning
outcomes, the
learning objectives.
The key, one key,
is you have to know
what it is you want them to be
able to do when they get out.
I mean, it seems so
obvious, but you really
did-- you really
need to back into it.
So I try to think of a principal
way with these habits of mind
and foundational concepts
that Erin referred to,
which is core to our general
education program, which
was a year long.
And the idea was to
use production systems.
So I see Stewart
out there somewhere.
So a production system
was an early attempt
in an artificial
intelligence framework that
was largely popular
at Carnegie Mellon,
if I remember right,
Newell and Simon.
So the idea was you have
if-then construction,
so if it's raining,
then get an umbrella.
So there's a condition
part and an action part,
condition which is satisfied
triggers the action.
And there was tons and
tons of these things.
And the idea was
it'll be like dominoes
because once a trigger
is get an umbrella,
there's another one that says if
you want to get umbrella, then
go look in your closet
or look at the front door
or whatever it is.
So there are a whole
set of these things
that were together.
So thought about habits of mind
in terms of the condition part
being really straightforward
and relatively easy to implement
so it could become automatic.
That's where the habit
idea came from, automatic.
So for example, one
of the ones at Minerva
is when you're
speaking to a group,
adjust what you say to be
appropriate for that group.
So think about it, speaking
to a group is easy.
I mean, it just
triggers automatically.
There it is, right?
But think about the second part.
Well, how do you adjust it?
Well, it depends on
what you're interested,
how much you already know,
how much time we have,
what my agenda is.
It's hard.
So when you teach,
here's the force of it.
When you teach, you
want to focus mostly
on that second part.
That's where it's hard.
Whereas the foundational
concepts are usually
the other way around.
Like with a t-test, a
simple statistical test,
the action part's really easy.
You just do this little
formula, compute it.
The hard part is knowing
when to apply it.
That's where
students get hung up.
So by using this framework
of production systems
to define these two classes
of learning objectives,
one is where the
condition part's hard,
the action's pretty
easy and vice versa, It
focused our attention
on where to teach.
This sounds really good, right?
Well, guess what, we're
dealing with faculty
who are trained elsewhere
in different systems.
So you know they tend to do?
What they're used to, the
way they were trained.
So to get faculty--
I spent a month at
a training course,
by the way, put together
with our new faculty
to try to get them to think
about things in different ways.
And it worked for a
while, but then it
starts eroding a little bit.
Old habits die hard.
So that was a big challenge.
There's actually a little
chapter in the book on that.
Yeah.
Well, actually, what are
some the common challenges
that you found in
training the Minerva
faculty to adopt this approach.
My assumption is that most
of the Minerva faculty
didn't actually attend an
intentional university,
so they had a lot of
learning to do as well.
So yeah, what are some of
the common things you found?
Well, the most
common problem we had
was the sage on the
stage impulse, the idea
that I'm really not
teaching well if they
didn't take a lot of notes.
And, you know, I should be
conveying a lot of information.
So the whole structure
of Minerva classes
is based on active
learning because that's
how you can really implement
the science of learning
effectively, get
them to do things.
But they have to know
something in order
to do something with it, right?
So the model there was
a flipped classroom
where they did a lot
of reading in advance
and so forth, some nights
watched videos, watched tapes,
and then in class, the idea was
to have them actively engaged
as Erin--
Erin said.
But there was a tendency
for a lot of faculty
to feel like they really
needed to intervene,
they really needed
to supplement,
and so forth, which is coming
from a good place, by the way,
I don't mean to say that
it's completely misguided.
But it takes some
artistry to do that
in a way that doesn't undermine
the students' the students'
motivation.
Senator Kerrey, can you
speak to this question
of some examples in
your own experience
where you've tried to translate
some evidence-based principle
and put it into practice?
Not really.
No, but I-- some of these are
really quite appealing to me
about Minerva,
that drew me to it.
I mean, Stephen's presence
helped a great deal.
I mean, and one of the-- one
of the presumptions in keeping
the students together,
but sending them
out to international
cities is based upon,
not-- it's not actually
based, but it's
connected to an
experience that I've
had over and over and over,
which is if you put yourself
in an uncomfortable
position intentionally,
and I'm talking
culturally uncomfortable,
and you are respectful,
there's a lot
that you can learn in a hurry.
You can learn to
conquer your discomfort,
and as a consequence, you begin
to understand the culture,
and you make new friends,
and all of a sudden,
knowledge becomes
different because it's--
it's going to look different
in different cities
and different cultures.
So I love the idea that
it's a residential program,
but the students after they
do their foundation year
in San Francisco are
going to be in six
different international
cities before they graduate.
The fork in the road
actually that I also
like that gets into a bit of
controversy, which I enjoy,
I actually don't like--
I like arguments better than
dialogue, just so you know.
So when this gets into Q&A,
if I bring somebody to tears,
I apologize ahead of time.
When I was president
the New School,
one things I was aware of is the
cost of maintaining buildings.
You've got to pass them
on to the students.
And the most difficult
fork in the road
is, I'm just asking
this question,
as an adult, if you
want to learn something
do you go sit in a classroom
and wait for somebody to show up
and teach you.
It's apt to be you're
pulling up your cell phone.
It's apt to be that you're
looking at software.
So what Minerva did is
built a virtual classroom,
but Stephen is sitting right
next to the guy who's doing.
He doesn't have to
go down and schedule
a meeting in of the IT people.
The platform, the
virtual classroom,
is built for Stephen.
And if it works academically,
it works technically.
And if it doesn't
work academically,
it doesn't work technically.
And there have been challenges
all the way along the line.
And you cannot come to class--
this is also
connected to something
that I've learned
along the way, and I
see failures in every
organization, not just higher
education.
If you pass by something
that's substandard
and don't do anything about
it, that's the new standard.
And you see it all the time.
So the hardest standard
to keep fixed on
is expecting the
students to do the work.
And you can't come into
a Minerva classroom
and sit in the back row because
the professor knows what you
know and what you don't know.
And by the way, Minerva
is not hiring adjuncts.
We don't do it on the cheap.
We're not trying to get the
cheapest people you possibly
can because our own experience
is that you're much more
likely to have low-performing
people if that's all you do.
But there's real engagement.
It's hard.
It's really hard.
You know, if you've
got students that
have an interest in
Minerva, I would recommend
you really do an
evaluation whether or not
they can do the work.
It's not easy.
The standard is very high
in terms of performance.
The last thing I would say
is, my own experience in life
taught me this, that--
and I heard a lot
in higher education.
I heard a lot in politics.
But just stick with politics.
I know there's a little politics
going on in higher education
as well.
But the word hypocrite
gets thrown around a lot.
You're a hypocrite.
Well, I'm now when people say
to me you're a hypocrite, I say,
well, that's--
that's evidence that
I have standards.
I'm not capable of hypocrisy
unless I've got standards
that I sometimes don't hit.
And Stephen and I have been
confronting a little hypocrisy
at Minerva in that we've got
highly-qualified students
that we're turning away.
Why are we turning them away?
Because of US News
and World Report
because of the Wall
Street Journal.
They decide what our
standard-- because they
have a selectivity number.
What's you're selectivity?
How many people apply?
How many people get turned away?
And your quality is judged
based upon the number
of people you turn away.
That's hypocrisy.
Now you need to embrace
it, it seems to me,
because it leads you
to try to figure out
how to work your way out of it.
I was telling your
president, I would--
I was 10 years at the New
School in New York City.
I went to New York City
because my girlfriend would not
agree to marry me
unless I agreed
to try to have another child.
And I didn't want to raise two
more kids in politics, and I--
by the way, I think I hit the
last egg she had because we now
have a 17-year-old.
And we'd go to
these social events,
and if you go to a social event
in New York City and the people
walk up to you and say, well,
where did you go to school?
And they did not want to hear
the University of Nebraska.
And I said, well, oh the
University of-- my wife,
by the way, dropped
out of high school.
She wanted to be a writer.
And, you know, she
did relatively well.
She wrote for Saturday
Night Live for a long time
and did very well as a writer.
She went to John
Jay High School.
She would answer the
question, I went to John Jay.
They thought she was
in criminal justice.
So they'd leave her alone.
So I said to your
president, if you
could unpack this
crazy head of mine
and take 100,000 ideas
that I have about life,
I bet 20% of it came from
Harvard or people from Harvard.
A significant amount of what I
know about how teaching is done
came from Stephen Kosslyn.
So I said, you really--
your motto ought to
be je suis Harvard.
Let me claim Harvard
rather than saying I have
to go to school at Harvard.
I have to be eligible to join
the Harvard Club in New York
City in order to be a
part of the fraternity
because I'm constantly reading,
and analyzing, and acquiring
things that come about as a
result of the democratization
of knowledge that's occurring
in the modern university.
And Harvard is
the gold standard.
So I do think for me,
learning to survive
in an uncomfortable
environment, learning
that you can have
very high standards,
but you got to hold
to those standards,
and learning that
there are times
when you have to honestly
face your own hypocrisy
and embrace it.
Sometimes it's necessary.
Sometimes it's essential.
People say to me, I've never
done anything hypocritical.
No, there's nothing worse
than lying to yourself.
You know, I understand why
you'd lie to somebody else,
but lying to yourself
can be dangerous.
I'm not sure how you
follow that, but--
[LAUGHTER]
Let me ask the more
pedestrian question then.
How do you know
when it's working?
I mean, how-- how
do you evaluate
when the science of
teaching and learning
apply to actual
is actually producing
better outcomes?
So I think a key word
you just said was the it.
What do you mean by it?
The quality and effectiveness
of the teaching.
OK, so the first
thing is you have
to know what the outcomes
are supposed to be.
So you've got to start with
clearly-defined learning
outcomes, and you've got to
directly address them in class,
and then you've
got to assess them.
It's pretty straightforward.
But it turns out that we
retain only maybe at best
about 10% of what we
get from a lecture
after maybe three months.
Some of the studies show
a lot less than that.
After active learning,
it can be like 70%,
Eric Mazur is here somewhere.
He knows this very
well, much better.
But what you want
to do in my opinion
is not just test them at
the end of the semester,
but how about a year later?
I mean, if we're
really teaching them
with the idea of
giving them tools
they can use the rest of their
lives, which I hope we are,
maybe we should assess
to the extent to which
what we teach them sticks.
Yeah, look, I think for us,
when you're starting something
like that, which can be very
anxiety producing because you
never know if you're going to
be able to raise enough money
to stay in business.
So it's not like
somebody gives you
a couple hundred million gift.
It's not easy to keep
it going because you're
regulated by the state.
You're regulated by the feds.
There's lots of things going
on that could produce failure.
So it seems to me that
the most important metric
is what the students say.
And maybe the most important
metric of all is do they come
back the sophomore
year after they've--
they've had their freshman year.
These are students who could go
anywhere, practically anywhere.
I don't know how
many of them have
got accepted into
Harvard or MIT,
but a significant number of them
get into high-quality schools.
There's no guarentee.
I mean, we start off
with a class of students.
We can't say to them
with absolute certainty
you're going to
graduate because we
don't know if we're
going to be around
in order for them to graduate.
Now, we're going to
graduate a class in May.
So we are going to have one
graduating class at least.
I think we're going to
have more than that.
But they came back
the sophomore year.
Our beginning class,
those students
had to do a gap year in
between their freshman year
and sophomore year in
order to be a line up.
Those are really brave
kids that did that.
And they came back
their sophomore year.
About 95% of them came
back in the sophomore year.
So I think the most important
test is, are the students--
do the students like it?
Are they saying, this
is working for me?
So you're not at a point
yet where you're actually
able to assess longer-term
outcomes, right,
so how your graduates are
doing after year one, two,
three postgraduate?
There are no graduates yet.
Yeah, no graduates yet.
No, no, they're not.
This year.
So at Minerva, the faculty are
singularly focused on teaching.
And the undergraduates
are singularly
focused on the
academic experience.
But as you know, at
Harvard, our faculty
are engaged in research
and teaching, which
reflects our own institutional
commitment to knowledge
production.
And our students learn not
only through the curriculum,
but also through their
extracurricular commitments
and, of course, the
residential community
that they're a part of.
So from that perspective, how
well does the Minerva model
travel to places like Harvard?
What types of adaptations do
you think would be necessary?
Well, first of
all, I don't think
it has to travel to Harvard.
You know, I don't--
Harvard is the best
university in the world.
So it's not like you've
got a failure going here.
And by the way,
this is the tenth--
So we're not-- so we're
not one of the campuses
where students learn
remarkably little?
I-- I don't make that
claim at all because,
look, I think the most
important learning occurs
after you leave college anyway.
So the question is, are you
are you prepared to learn?
Are you willing to learn?
Do you have a sufficient
amount of humility
to recognize that the most
productive moment of your life
occurs right after you
discover something you believed
for a long time is wrong?
So do you have that
attitude when you graduate?
It's going to determine
how well you do in life.
All these kids have
plenty of intelligence.
They all have plenty of energy.
The only thing that's going
to determine whether or not
somebody wants to be their
friend, or their husband
or their wife is
whether or not they've
got the right character.
And, you know, that's
difficult to teach.
So Harvard-- the only
thing I worry about Harvard
is, you know, is
you guys getting too
worked up over the
fact that you're elite.
I don't think there's anything
necessarily wrong with that.
I don't think you have
to be a quarterback
to have that qualifying
adjective on the word.
And I'll repeat it, I do
think, as far as I'm concerned,
a significant part of my
thinking has come from Harvard.
But I didn't spend a day here
in this class, in classes here.
So I think you are disseminating
a substantial amount
of knowledge, and by the way,
Stephen can talk about this.
One of the powerful--
most powerful things--
one of the most powerful things
at Minerva that I really like
is there's a constant
improvement of the curriculum,
daily improvement of
the curriculum based
upon actually doing research
in the classroom on what works.
And so you don't have to have
committee meetings to discuss
the general education curricula.
You don't have to have, you
know, these painful gatherings,
having a meeting to decide
how many more meetings you're
going to have.
None of that has to--
has to occur.
And I understand it's necessary.
I'm not-- I'm being
critical of it
in a well-established,
400-year-old institution.
But at Minerva, there
is research going on,
and the research is, what works?
You should elaborate on that.
Let me loop back a little bit.
I think your question
really struck
to the heart of an
essential tension at an R1,
at a place like Harvard, which
is the incentive structure here
is set up around research.
That's how people get promoted.
That's what's really rewarding.
So how do you integrate
the research culture
with high-quality teaching?
I think that really
is in some sense
the core of the dilemma
that's facing Harvard.
So when I first started--
so I was the first faculty
member hired at Minerva,
and I set up the academic
program there, and so on.
And one of the first
things that I worried about
was the fact we had no labs.
And what if the students
wanted to go to med school?
What was going to happen?
So I sent email to deans
of several medical schools,
and arranged phone calls,
and talked to them about it,
and just--
I call it the beaker problem.
We have no beakers
because it's--
all the classes are
taught via a platform.
It's on the computer.
It's in real time.
It's a seminar.
Everybody is there
at the same time.
It's not the standard distance
education, asynchronous.
It's asynchronous.
But nevertheless,
there are no beakers.
And one of the things
that came through in all
of the conversations I had
with deans of medical schools
is they actually didn't care
about the standard laboratory
exercises that are attached
to organic chemistry,
or some of the bio
courses, and so forth.
They thought they were
kind of a waste of time
because in the real
world, you don't
know the answer in advance.
There are no set set
of steps that you have
to go through to get it right.
What they cared about, what
they really cared about,
was the students should
have some actual experience
in a real lab like
say over the summer
in a real lab
where they actually
did experiential learning.
So I think a place
like Harvard where
everybody, all the faculty
are involved in research,
and I'm not just
talking the sciences.
I mean, humanists
do research too.
Every single one
of those faculty
has opportunities for students
to have experiential learning,
to actually see what it's like
to work on the cutting edge.
I mean, that's the
point of a place
like this from my perspective.
I mean, one of my kids went here
and had a wonderful experience,
by the way, in part because
of all these opportunities.
So I think the deal
is to figure out
how to systematize that,
how to build it into the DNA
so it's part of the institution
so that the expectations are
there for both the
students and faculty,
this is part of what you do.
And part of that may
involve changing incentives
a little bit, which we
can talk about later.
Anymore thoughts on that?
Well, moving away
from Harvard, let's
say at the community
colleges, which
educate half of all of
higher education in America,
one of the great
challenges there,
actually there's two
that I see immediately,
one that gets
almost no attention
deserves a lot more,
which is governance.
How are these
institutions governed?
Anybody who's spent any
time in the K-12 environment
will tell you that
it can be miserable
dealing with the school board
because there's an election.
And you've got 5 out of 8
vote to go this direction,
have an election, and
those five get thrown out
of office because of the
conflicting objectives
that the population has.
I want to save money.
I want to spend more money.
I want to make sure
they're prepared for work.
I want them prepared
for college.
I want them to learn
foreign languages.
I want them to
learn sex education.
Whatever.
We just we have all these
different things we want.
And the public school board
has to make that decision.
Well, the same is true
in higher education,
you know, if you ask somebody
in my neighborhood in New York
City, in the village,
how did NYU get
to be such a good university?
They'll talk, well, Brademas
did a great job, Sexton.
They'll talk about
the leadership.
But the person who made
NYU a great university
was Larry Tisch.
He was the chairman of
the board for 20 years.
And every time there was
a piece of real estate
in the marketplace that he
thought they should buy,
he'd write a check.
And, you know, they bought
up Greenwich Village property
for like pennies on the dollar.
And they converted
a commuter school
into a residential
university as a consequence.
Well, governance in
the community college
becomes enormously important.
And second thing at
the community college
level, and we see it at
Minerva, and you may see even
at Harvard, I mean, do I
really want to charge somebody
$600 a credit hour to get
three credits in something
that they can get
online for nothing?
And it's there.
You know, we have
a list of things
we want our students to learn.
And we expect them
to go learn it,
but we're not going
to charge them for it.
We're not going to give
them credit for it.
Not only does it lower
the cost, but it also
encourages them to learn the
way they're going to learn
when they get out of college.
You're encouraging them to try
to use available resources,
and they're
phenomenal out there.
And it's enormously
controversial.
If I spent 20 years
of my life learning
how to teach
Accounting 101 and 102,
I wouldn't be very excited
if Bob Kerrey says,
you can go online
and get it for $50.
It can be a little disturbing
to find myself in that position.
But it unquestionably is there.
And it's one of the
most difficult things,
it seems to me, especially at
at the community college level
that we face.
So, Steve, I think you're
alluding in your earlier
remarks to the need to maybe
rethink some of the incentives
so that we can really
capitalize on the synergies
between research and teaching
in a setting like Harvard.
Can you say more about that?
I don't think I have anything
particular profound, or deep,
or original to say about it.
I mean, it needs to be
the case that people
are rewarded for good teaching.
And the question is how to
structure those rewards.
So you can do things
like have more prizes,
have a big symposium
at the end of the year,
give some publicity to people
who've won those prizes,
the coin of the realm,
things like pay raises,
and additional leaves.
I mean, get serious about it.
If in fact, teaching
is valued, reward it.
Look, there's a terrific
book that's not an education.
It's on health care.
It's called The Language of
Kindness written by a woman.
She's a very good
writer, but she
was a nurse, a pediatric nurse,
in their National Health System
in England.
And it's a story about
the imperfectability
of human beings.
And it's, you know, I don't know
if you think we're perfectable,
I got news for you, you
got some real significant
disappointments down the road.
And what she's saying is,
I'm a great nurse on Monday,
and something horrible
happened Monday night.
I had a terrible
loss in my family,
and I got to go to
work on Tuesday.
And I can't go to work and say,
hey, you got to understand,
you're the patient.
You got to understand
that something horrible
happened in my life.
And I mean, it's--
I'm not saying that students are
like emergency room patients,
but it can be-- it
can wear you out.
It's got to at some point.
It's got to at some point you
can say, you know, this is--
I need a break.
I don't actually
know how you do it,
those of you who
are faculty members.
I mean, you love to teach.
But at some moment, it may occur
you stopped loving to teach.
I mean, so it's
a great challenge
to figure out how
to deal with it,
how to adjust, how to
organizationally make
adjustments that are fair
and reasonable, especially
in a country where, if you
decide you don't want to teach
anymore, you've got to
answer the question,
how do I-- how do I pay
my health care bills
and how do I retire on a
pitiful amount of income
coming through Social Security?
So it's a difficult problem.
But I think it's honesty.
At some point, you
just say, I got
to do something else because
it's a constant challenge,
and you're being measured, and
you're being evaluated, and--
and people-- now you've
got one of the-- what's
the thing called where
you can go to a website
and judge your
college professor?
What's it called?
Rate My Professor.
Oh, my god, I mean, I--
I would-- I would not--
I would quit if they--
or I'd shoot myself if I
find myself in a situation
where I get 19-year-old students
are telling me that they didn't
like me on Monday afternoon.
Well, guess what?
Life's hard.
Go-- you know, that
would be my attitude.
So what excites you most
about the future, other
than the next iteration
of Rate My Professor?
Oh, I'm 75.
The most exciting thing
is that there is a future.
[LAUGHTER]
How about you too?
Like what--
[LAUGHTER]
I can't follow
something like that.
Yeah, it was an interesting
choice having two of us here.
You're getting this
very dry science
of learning, read
all this stuff, let
me tell you about it.
And he's bringing the art.
And he's like lived it, and
he's telling you about it.
Yeah.
So exactly.
Perfect in counterpoint.
Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
I think we've learned a
huge amount about learning,
which should inform teaching.
It's not the same thing.
And in particular, I think
there's huge opportunities
for--
with technology
in creative ways.
Great.
Well, I mean, I do think--
I'm not recommending
any change at Harvard.
Any change in any
university is difficult,
but for those of you who think
Minerva is an online program,
it's not.
This virtual classroom it's
powerful, really powerful,
because I can--
all the time that
any administrator
puts into arranging
the meetings,
they're called classes,
between faculty and students,
the regulatory
friction to arrange
those meetings is substantial.
And the cost to heat, to
cool, to maintain classrooms
that get used, if you
subtract 8 hours from 24,
you'll be lucky still to get
50% utilization of that space.
We can recruit faculty
from all over the world.
They just have to be in
the class at the time.
The students-- the
students say, oh, my gosh I
got to get home for the weekend.
That's not an excuse
to miss class.
So it is-- and you can
evaluate constantly.
We process the data.
We evaluate our faculty.
We make changes constantly
in the curriculum
on a daily basis as a
result of seeing what works
and what doesn't work.
So it's a really powerful
tool, and it's vastly better.
I understand it's, you know,
we all like to get together.
That's why we have a
residential program.
And the last thing I'd
say, and I appreciate what
your president said about need.
He was telling me offline
that if your income is
less than $60,000, you'll
pay nothing to go to Harvard.
Well, financial need is
a big problem at Minerva.
We we're militantly
need blind, militantly.
75% of our students
are international.
And one of the dirty, little
secrets in American higher
education, we're
all hungry, I mean,
Harvard probably isn't,
but across the country
we want to enroll
international students
because they pay full price.
They're not eligible
for Title IV,
and they subsidize
the domestic students.
So we run-- we have 75% of our
students are international.
And even though our tuition is,
what is it? $10,000 or $11,000
now?
And room and board $15,000?
It's $25,000 cash.
That's a lot of money for
families all over the world.
So you run into tremendous
need in higher education,
financial need, that
oftentimes is a barrier,
and it can be, my guest
is Harvard's got programs
in place for those students
who find themselves
with a couple hundred
dollars short,
and that couple
hundred bucks can
make the difference between
them surviving and not surviving
in a environment
that's, you know,
that's difficult and
different for them.
So I'd like you to end
hopefully on an inspiring note.
Uh-huh.
I can't do that.
[LAUGHTER]
There is a-- in the
foreword to the book,
you encouraged us
all to, as you said,
remember that moment when
a great teacher enabled
you to change the
course of your life,
that moment when you were
mentored through whatever
challenge you were facing.
And so I wonder if you
could describe such a moment
in your own lives and
how it shaped the values
and actions that
you have brought
to your work and leadership.
Yeah, I was given the
question before we came,
so I knew it was on
the way, but I mean,
I learn every day from
people that teach me things.
And it-- it usually occurs
in unexpected moments.
But, formally, I had
a science teacher
in high school, Mr. Reese, and
I fell in love with science,
because of his attitude
towards exploration,
and discovery, and the
methodology of science.
When I got out of service,
I went out to-- actually,
I was enrolled at
Stanford Business School,
and I went to see the registrar
in the summer of 1970,
and I looked at the
courses I would be taking,
and I said, Jesus,
I don't need this.
And the guy says to me,
oh, you're from Nebraska.
Do you like Willa Cather?
I don't know who
the hell she was.
So I went to the
library, and I said,
I can't go to a business school
if I don't do Willa Cather is,
so I went to--
went to California,
San Francisco,
and I had a professor,
my first professor there,
taught me how to read.
I thought I knew how to read.
I could decode, but
I had no capacity
to understand what it meant
to actually comprehend and own
a novel or a work of nonfiction.
So those are the two
in formal settings--
two-- I had a third
one, actually,
probably not relevant
to higher education,
but I had childhood asthma
pretty bad, and I was--
I went out for football.
I played football, and I
had three deficiencies.
I was small, slow, and weak.
Other than that--
[LAUGHTER]
So I mean, I trained myself
to snap the ball four punts.
That's really what my skill was.
And I expected to start
my senior year, and--
and that's when the asthma
really broke off from labor day
to the first freeze.
And I didn't make the first
traveling squad and quit,
and I went home, and my
dad said, you can't quit.
And I went back, and
I told the coach,
and he said, just stick around.
We'll see what happens.
Well, the first game, the
center snapped the ball
over the head of the
punter five times,
and I started every
game after that.
And what it taught
me, and I've applied
it is there are moments when
quitting is the right thing
to do.
But there are moments when it's
the absolute worst thing to do.
Thank you.
Stephen.
So it's funny how sometimes
really small things
can compound, compound and
so forth, and end up changing
your life in profound ways.
So in my case, I was a
graduate student in Stanford,
and they have a
first-year project.
You have to do an experiment.
And I was doing an
experiment to test a computer
model of long-term memory
then, where we gave people
statements, and they had
to say true or false.
We measured the response time.
And I won't go through the
details, but one of the items
was a flea can bite.
And two people in a
row responded, no.
Now, I lived with cats then,
so I knew a lot about fleas.
So I interview them
after the study.
And one of them said, I looked
to see if there were teeth,
and I couldn't see any teeth.
The other ones said,
I look for a mouth,
and it wasn't big enough to
get around skin, looked, see.
This had nothing to do
with the computer model.
So I went and called
back everybody
who'd been in the study and
said, did you visualize?
And they said yes or no.
And I then looked at the
data, and it turned out
the people said they visualized
were faster for the larger
properties, like does a mouse
have a back that was faster
than as a mouse had whiskers?
Whereas the people
who didn't visualize,
it was the other way around.
The thing.
It was more associated.
Whiskers is more associated
with the mouse say than bat,
completely different
plan and strategy.
So I started studying
mental imagery.
I suddenly changed completely.
It turned out there was a
faculty member at Stanford
named Gordon Bower,
who'd just written
a paper on mental imagery.
He was in Germany at the time.
I hadn't met him, but I
got a preprinted paper.
So it was useful to be there.
I read the paper, and
there was a one line in it
that set my entire career.
He said, if mental images were
like pictures that could be
scanned, then blah, blah, blah.
Well, nobody had tested that.
So I went and
tested it and showed
the further you scan along
an object in a mental image,
the longer it takes.
There really is
something spatial there
Gordon came back.
Meanwhile, my
advisor dropped out
to join the Ecology Movement and
told me to do the same thing,
by the way.
It was 1970.
At Stanford, they had
this Friday seminar
where graduate students
have to present their work,
and it's very critical.
And Gordon tore into me.
I'll never forget this
the rest of my life.
I mean, he really tore into me.
And, you know, I thought about
it, and it was interesting.
And the next day
after that, I was
in the lounge on the
fourth floor, Jordan Hall,
and he walked in.
And I was getting a
Coke or something,
and he started talking to me.
And we sat, and we talked
for like an hour and a half.
And I remember another
faculty member, Herb Carr,
came by and sat and
watch for a while.
It was like a game of
ping pong with Gordon.
And then he started coming by
and giving me papers and stuff,
just dropping by my office.
And he became my
advisor and quite
a close friend now,
actually, and still
is my advisor in
many, many ways.
And he gave me foundations,
how to think clearly
and critically, and value the
importance of what's known,
and be skeptical and
critical about it.
And he also gave me
feedback, which by the way
is an important
principle of learning,
to correct when I wasn't
getting things quite right.
So having met that guy
just changed my life
for the better in so many ways.
Thank you.
Thank you-- actually, thank you
both for sharing those moments.
And obviously, thank
you for the conversation
and-- and for your
continuing work
on these important questions.
And thank you, and thank
you all for your interest.
It's great to be
back here again.
And Erin, thanks
for organizing this.
[APPLAUSE]